the jurgen experience one of the things
i
learned from all the men who were
writing into me at playboy
is um jordan peterson has something that
really speaks to these guys
and you know i've seen him get a lot of
crap but like he has
saved so many men that i know i mean
these guys have written me letters like
telling me so much and i'm not sure
really what it is about his
program or whatever what whatever it is
that he's saying his message
well he's concentrating on young men i
mean
he has this he's resonating with young
men because is it discipline
what is his what is his primary i think
he always talks about cleaning your room
like cleaning
right right right make your bed messy
mind
yeah same thing i mean he's essentially
saying clean your room getting your [ __ ]
together
yeah and i mean there's there's so much
to what he's saying
that expands far beyond that as well and
you know his movies are good he says
there's a documentary about him right
now the rise of jordan peterson
is getting censored right these people
are protesting at being in these
theaters they don't know
they think they're supposed to censor
him they think he's transphobic and
homophobic and all these different
things
but he's helped so many people but you
know his origin do you know what
happened in toronto
no okay there was there was a bill that
was being passed it was going to force
you to use
one of you know there's this gender
pronoun bill
like say if you wanted to use one of the
78 different gender pronouns
you would be obligated like legally
obligated to use them
and he was protesting against that it's
like you're using compelled speech
canada does not have free speech they do
not have the first amendment
that it wasn't that he didn't want to
use their
preferred pronoun it was that he didn't
want to be compelled to use it legally
legally he didn't want to use made-up
words either right like because there's
zizer and jim
and all these different crazy made up
words yeah like
like you you want to be a vey you want
to be a
a he or a she like like what are we
doing here
yeah yeah who what are you okay if you
you want me to call
bruce jenner caitlyn jenner okay i'll
call her that's fine you want me to say
it to her okay i'll say it's okay that's
fine i don't care i don't give a [ __ ]
but you want to start making up words
and that's where he's like no and you
want to
call me and you want to call me a bigot
for not letting my kid get hormones
like this is where this is where or the
sports thing i get very like
outrageous about that that's insane it's
insane there's
there's a bunch of different schools
that are letting kids
compete in the gender that they identify
with and those
in those places those those women's
track events are [ __ ] dominated by
men
dominated they're breaking world records
was that woman's name rachel mckinnon
she just broke the world's record for
the cycling event
and she's she used to be a man i mean
all the like you're a bigot if you don't
agree with this no you broke the world's
record
how'd that happen what is happening here
what's happening here is you're a guy
this is when i born a guy
this is when i feel like i'm in a
simulation and
right right and there's somebody who's
like let's see how many people we can
get
to like get on board with this [ __ ]
right and then
and i i and or i'm like maybe i'm just
old
no maybe no what's getting what's
happening is women are getting [ __ ]
over
that's why this is the most crazy i get
called a turf a lot
but they're in the middle of this
ideological battle
and women are losing scholarships
they're they're losing their ability to
compete with people of their own gender
this is or their own sex their own
whatever you want to call it whatever
the
[ __ ] chromosomes when you start
adding
trans men and trans women into the mix
you're going to get two things depending
upon the sport the trans men are going
to get [ __ ] smoked
period when tran when women transition
to men and they want to be a man and
compete with men they're going to get
[ __ ] up
in almost every sport particularly
fighting it is funny how much
it's gotten men talking about periods
like it's just like you know i'll see
men defending like a woman's right
to talk about her period i'm like yes
that's right now you're a male
feminist what man has ever had a problem
with women talking about their period no
no i know but so they're they they exist
they're squeamish that is so weak mushy
that's mushy man
guys are scared of [ __ ] blood you're
not scared of a bloody steak but you're
scared of vagina blood yeah there's they
are there are guys who are squeamish
about it and there's
another one shake them off the leaf yeah
yeah
pick them up
it does feel a banana i read something
somewhere where it said
you know that there was um
gender like stereotypes were being
determined by biology
and now we're using biology now we're
using
gender to determine biology as
so biology determined gender stereotypes
the male and the female whatever
and there was a reaction to that and now
is a reaction
to it they're using gender to determine
biology and how it's getting yeah
it's like it's so confusing it's so
maybe
it's just a broad spectrum of people and
there's low testosterone males there's
high testosterone females
and that should be okay we should be
allowed to be whatever the [ __ ] we want
you